dedication day for the new National
Library of Medicine building in Bethesda
Maryland the library's Board of Regents
and many distinguished guests arrived
doctors from the United States and other
nations ambassadors and members of the
diplomatic corps congressmen senators
military and civilian leaders
today we come together to dedicate a
great new facility for the greatest
medical library in the world the
National Library of Medicine 125 years
ago as one of his last official act dr.
Joseph level Surgeon General of the
United States authorized a budget item
which called for one hundred and fifty
dollars for medical books less simply
and modestly began the amassing or the
great collection which is today the
National Library of Medicine this
country owes a great debt to dr. Lovell
and the generations of army officers who
followed him for their vision and
perseverance the human are the guardians
of this knowledge which has been
accumulated over the centuries unto you
these called tasks it will be to
preserve and enshrine the advances of
tomorrow's we at this hour turn over
this magnificent building which will be
a repository of ancient truths and
future discoveries
this is an important day in the history
of the National Library of Medicine the
building is new but the institution and
its tradition of service are more than
125 years old the library is a tribute
to those whose foresight and years of
work led to this realization of an ideal
to men such as Robert Fletcher surgeon
avid cataloger and bibliography
fielding H garrison Doctor of Medicine
dedicated librarian and historian and
dr. John Shaw Billings without a doubt
the library's greatest debt is to dr.
Billings as a commissioned medical
officer during the Civil War he was
assigned to the surgeon general's office
in Washington in 1864 under his charge
the small library of the Surgeon General
grew from the 1365 volumes listed in the
1864 catalog to some 117 thousand books
and 150 mm pathways
to house the collections he planned a
new building that was erected on the
mall in Washington
in this building the library was opened
to the public in 1888 in 1876 dr.
Billings published a specimen fasciculus
to illustrate his design for the
world-famous index catalogue of the
library of the surgeon general's office
typical of his vision was the name he
chose for the collection the National
Medical Library
the monumental task of compiling and
publishing the index catalog began in
1880 and continued until a total of
three million author subject references
had been published by the library in 61
volumes and five series
starting in 1950 to keep pace with
current acquisitions the index catalog
was replaced by a monthly journal index
and an annual catalog of books
when quani accumulations of the annual
catalog are published in several volumes
another contribution of doctor Billings
was the index Medicus prepared with the
help of dr. fletcher this was a monthly
bibliographic key to current medical
literature
today's index Medicus lists over 12,000
articles each month by author and
subject the literature is published in
some 30 languages John Shaw Billings
contributions to the world of medical
science were immense certainly one of
his greatest legacies was the
institution given formal statutory base
in 1956 in that year
senators Hill and Kennedy initiated
legislation that became the National
Library of Medicine Act under which
authority the jurisdiction over the
library was transferred from the
military to the Public Health Service
in 1961 this reading room had been in
use for 73 years the collection of a few
hundred volumes had grown to 1 million
100,000 books serials and pamphlets and
was increasing by 80,000 items annually
the old red brick building had served
its purpose well and far beyond the
original requirements
while leave-taking was filled with
nostalgia and formed memories for the
staff and director the feeling soon
passed because a new building was
waiting a building great in size yet
gracious in design with the most
carefully planned facilities was opened
for service in April 1962 equipped and
staffed by the United States government
for service to all who work in the
fields of medical sciences
inside old friends meet in new
surroundings
a welcome sight to scholars and
physicians is the history of Medicine
collection consisting of hundreds of
reference volumes for the students of
medical history and thousands of medical
works published before 1801
the collection includes many early
manuscripts and in Kanab EULA
such as the Canon of Avicenna
in an Arabic manuscript
in a Latin manuscript
in a hebrew edition of 1491
and in a Latin edition of 1479
it includes the classics of Medicine
Galen
Lucilius
Harvey
and the multifold works of other men
the library's Board of Regents meets
behind the scenes in the new building
its duties as defined by the National
Library of Medicine Act are to advise
consult with and make recommendations to
the Surgeon General
thus the agenda of these meetings deal
with every area of the library's service
first in the tradition of the past is
the acquisition and exchange of books
and serials which constitute the
literature of medicine over two hundred
bibliographies and publishers lists from
all nations are continually examined and
checked for items to be ordered for the
library in an acquisition program that
covers the entire world this results in
the arrival of hundreds of items each
day
the pieces received are sorted checked
in
and arranged for delivery to various
work areas
in the catalog section and free forms
and subject headings are selected and
books are classified
cataloging records are typed on maps for
the reproduction of cards
many of the cards are destined for use
in the public catalog under main entry
and subject entry
other copies of the cards will be used
for the published catalog
to provide a bridge from the catalog
records to the actual volume on the
shelves a call number is lettered on
each volume The Binding section provides
for the binding of pamphlets and repair
of volumes and arranges for the
necessary binding of journals and
monographs outside the library
another item on the Board of Regents
agenda is a continuing study of the
mechanization of indexing of journals
high-speed automated equipment helps the
library's indexers provide 150,000
current references annually
daily about 60 medical journals
containing some 800 articles are
delivered to the indexers who compile
the information to be printed in the
index Medicus
to assist in this work
a dictionary file is maintained to
record the new drug chemical medical and
foreign language terms that cannot be
found in published dictionaries and
reference books the indexers assigned
subject headings and translate foreign
language titles
the assigned subject headings are
converted into numerical equivalence
then with perforated tapes and keypunch
equipment a million cards a year are
punched automatically typed
sorted combined collated and match
these cards provide the author and
subject listings to be photographed for
offset reproduction in the monthly index
Medicus yearly accumulated index Medicus
and the bibliography of medical
reviewers but daily the volume of
scientific literature is increasing and
the total articles to be indexed may
soon exceed 180,000 annually to meet the
challenge of increased volume workflow
patterns are rearranged and refined as
new business machines are acquired
eventually fully automated systems will
provide for the storage of information
on magnetic tapes from which
bibliographies can be furnished
on-demand this application of automation
as conceived by the library is known as
meddlers medical literature analysis and
retrieval system acquisition cataloguing
and indexing are the means to a common
objective building the collections and
providing the keys necessary for their
exploitation as the library's
collections move into the second million
every effort is made to meet the
worldwide demand for the use of this
accumulated knowledge
each year thousands of reference
questions are received and answered they
come by phone
and by mail from every continent
doctors scientists and writers also
bring their questions in person
this requires an active reference
service whether the request is routine
or unusual the information is supplied
when the need is authentic and local
sources are limited information on
dental education in Japan is selected
for a doctor in California
bibliographies are prepared to answer
some requests a list of references on
narcotic addiction for a physician in
Gaza a bibliography on planning a small
hospital for a doctor in Africa in some
instances the library strives to
anticipate demand by preparing
comprehensive bibliographies which are
duplicated and distributed
the library's international acquisition
program and its use of modern methods to
extend the record of its indexing and
cataloging operations naturally prompt
loan requests for source materials
the information on it's 45 miles of
shelves is freely available to all
workers in the medical sciences through
their local libraries including
monographs
journals
species
pamphlets early books
manuscript materials
and the picture collection on medical
subject portraits and caricatures
all this material is available for use
by those who come to the library in
person
it is also available by mail on
interlibrary loan
the requests increased daily and to keep
face with them requires methods that are
modern fast and precise
the information requested is
photographed with mobile cameras located
in the stack areas
total requests for material number over
125,000 per year and this means that a
new request must be handled every minute
of every working day
any library may participate the
mechanics are simple and efficient in a
library in Georgia a doctor needs
certain scientific information the local
librarian has determined that some of
this material is not in her collection
and suggests he may wish to have it
requested from the National Library of
Medicine
mailed to the National Library of
Medicine the request becomes part of the
500 received daily
the requests are sorted and taken to the
stack areas where the volumes are kept
the material is taken off the shelves
and carried to nearby photocopying
stations
the information requested is
photographed on film with the mobile
camera and the print is made in
approximately the size of the original
in this manner well over two million
pages of photo prints are sent to
borrowing libraries each year
the average order is received sorted
processed and forwarded within one week
a board of regents meeting may range
from acquisitions to xerography usually
it will include a discussion of
recruitment policies personnel and
training programs training programs such
as the one for library interns these are
some of the recent graduates of American
library schools who have been selected
from among many applicants after a year
of rotating assignments and seminar
discussions some will remain at the
library and some will accept positions
in other libraries this is one part of a
recruitment program that seeks the
highest type of employee the library
staff necessarily must be qualified in
many different types of work
the combined knowledge and ability of
the staff together with modern methods
furthers the vast undertaking began in
the distant past
all of these people are the mind the
heart and the strength of the library
the National Library Medicine will
continue to acquire maintain and make
available the finest and most complete
collection of medical literature and
reference material possible and to serve
all the work in the field of medicine